il faut d'abord
nominé
on est au 10 juillet
tu vas d'opale roulettes ont souillé
le vendeur me le dirait que les
améliorations qu'il faudrait porter
bassée en termes de sécurité par rapport
à au conducteur par rapport aux
voyageurs aussi il faut penser aux
voyageurs parce que très souvent ils
sont agressés et on est livré par le
même donc c'est mettre en place surtout
en terme de sécurité une cycle des
mobiles une sécurité présentes au niveau
de la télésurveillance au niveau de voix
la surveillance embarqué mobilité sur le
terrain à voir des gars qui sont qu'ils
soient là en cas d'agression pour une
intervention rapide bonjour je vends je
suis freegan d'un responsable
d'exploitation aux services transdev
service réunion avec le conseil général
et les forces de l'ordre on est bien
conscient que la sécurité est quelque
chose de prix mondial actuellement et
dans ce futur désolant lui
le conseil général a mis en place
dorénavant c'est on appris le volet
sibilité vraiment c'est un volet
vraiment important
bonjour je suis le chef d'escadron
thierry fouquet je commande l'ensemble
des gendarmes de l'est de l'île de la
réunion
la gendarmerie est présente sur
l'ensemble du territoire et à ce titre
lors de vos transports les forces de
gendarmerie sont régulièrement présente
vous les voyez régulièrement sur
l'ensemble de l'île de la réunion
je m'appelle alain casanova je suis
commandant de police je travaille à la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique de la réunion nous avons une
politique de partenariat avec les
transporteurs et particulier le réseau
car jaune par l'intermédiaire de la
société sotra d'air la police nationale
étant présente sur les villes
d'importance du département notamment
saint denis
notre présence aux côtés de deux
policiers municipaux et de contrôleurs
ce trader notamment dans les gares à
forte affluence contribuer à faire
baisser le sentiment d'insécurité
bonjour je m'appelle fabrice gros lot je
travaille chez ce travers donc la
société transports départementaux
je suis responsable des opérations
l'objectif est de de mettre l'accent sur
la sécurité des conducteurs qui se
sentent à l'aise pour travailler dans de
bonnes conditions qui ne soient pas
exposés à des désagréments dont kylie
ann nuire à leur travail au quotidien
il ya deux partenaires qui sont associés
donc surtout au niveau de la médiation
les agents de médiation ont un rôle
prépondérant dans ces dispositifs
bonjour je m'appelle jocelyn dominique
je suis directeur adjoint du jeu étaient
9 7 4
notre objectif est de promouvoir les
transports et de participer à
l'accompagnement et à l'assistance et
personne dans le transport en commun
dans le cadre de nos missions de
sécurité publique générale nous sommes
extrêmement présent de façon d'abord
préventive aux abords des gares
routières mais également sur le site des
arrêts de bus jugé dans ce doux sensible
est également vous nous voyez
régulièrement à l'intérieur de façon
embarqué au contact des contrôleurs pour
assurer une présence d'abord préventives
et dissuasives pour vous permettre de
voyager en toute sécurité
la présence des forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui est primordial dans la
mesure où
elle facilite la présentation donc du
justificatif d'identité pour le
contrôleur elle valorise son travail et
c'est un partenariat étroit qui se
développe entre les forces de l'ordre et
les contrôleurs la prévention elle est
notamment liée dont justement à la
prévenir le conflit à faire en sorte
qu'ils n'arrivent pas donc cela veut
dire intervenir dans de bonnes options
et dans de bonnes conditions pour que
sur le dirait la moindre irritation l'on
puisse rassurer le
les usagers et faire en sorte donc leur
voyage se passe dans les conditions qui
le désirent et qu'ils attendent à des
caméras embarquées dans les bus dans
tous les pisteurs qui voir qu'ils vont
arriver
ce sera au coup par coup à chaque fois
qu'il y aura un bus 9 le puits sont
équipées de caméras n'ont pas pouvoir
fliquer ou pouvoir surveiller le
conducteur mais vraiment pour sécuriser
leurs gains statistiquement les
et les infrastructures équipées de vidéo
surveillance
les statistiques mettent en avant une
baisse des problèmes d'insécurité
on espère que ce sera le cas sur les
autres car jaune notamment donc pour la
sécurité des conducteurs et des
des voyageurs le conseil général a
ramené quand même les moyens pour que
tous nos droits de tous nos voyageurs
voyage dans de bonnes conditions et
surtout dans des raisons dans des
situations de sécurité sans plus pour
autant de la mise en place de
de la répression c'est surtout dans
l'accompagnement c'est surtout dans un
monde bien accompagné rassurer c'est
surtout ça notre notre mission commune
on